desde que sucedió el terremoto en
afganistán las autoridades iraníes
venían llamando la atención de que esto
podría suceder en irán especialmente en
esta región del golfo pérsico donde
sucedió el terremoto o el doble
terremoto esta madrugada en un área
conocida como celler host en la
provincia de bandera lingue que como
sucede en afganistán son poblaciones
hechas de con casas hechas de barro y
ladrillo y realmente no son bastante
fuertes para soportar estos sismos las
autoridades hablan de 5 muertos y 50
personas heridas la mitad de ellas dadas
de alta ya la búsqueda ha terminado y
ahora todas las misiones están como dar
apoyo a aquellos que sobrevivieron al
menos 500 viviendas quedaron totalmente
destruidas otras quedaron imposible de
utilizar las autoridades están corriendo
para recolocar a estas familias las
condiciones climáticas especialmente de
esta zona son bastante difíciles tienen
44 grados en este momento en medio del
verano es una de las zonas más calientes
de la tierra por las cuales están
buscando si bien poner carpas como poner
aires acondicionados adentro darles agua
alimentación y ver como reubican a esta
gente por el momento